A coward dies, a thousand deaths, a soldier dies but one, one, one
[inaudible] to your papers. Poetry, power, distance,
40 kitchen picture and pitiful club. N****s, cop and police buffing. Greetings.
I position myself to clock. Geez my enemy. Scattered suicidal situations.
Never witnessed the Wiki shit that they was facing.
Fuck it's is back with precedent. Pursue your bridges.
He paid him to play a trick. White and switches,
which is just bad mouth cause Wallen motherfuckers is blow good shots.
The game should be so the secret sarcastic society. Somebody. Satan trauma.
So even Mama couldn't raise me keeping the preaching.
All my teachers couldn't reach me. The streets are buffing weed with my pizza.
Hey everybody. Jason Law head here for the Monday morning podcast.
We're here at the La sports arena and we're tonight's cage versus cons.
MMA octagon battle, but it's more than that man. We're down here. Beautiful Day.
It's been a tattoo festival has been a rap festival and we're going to get ready
for the red carpet. I'm here with the a the crime fighter comic.
Sam Tripoli from the naughty show podcast that
he wasn't given that, what are you thinking is Sam?
He was about to take off America's most wanted. I found everybody.
They're all right here today and uh, it's pretty awesome.
I have a healthy blend of both, uh, turned on and spirit. Chitlins yours.
We understand you're the guy that uh, is responsible for all of this.
All of these people, all of hey, that great. 21st I here.
Glad it's here tonight. We had been planning on this for like eight,
nine months now. So it's our first event.
We're really obviously excited about this.
You had to wait to all of the people got out of jail first. Yeah,
we made a couple of calls and said, come on,
let him out a little early today please. Anything of Savannah.
I need 16,000 pardons by 20.
You look at on court cases decide fights. Is that how you said? Yeah,
we looked at the dockets and we said, know these guys,
let them off a little early today please. So that's what happens. So it's great.
Great of leniency. Awesome event.
You don't have pro ball cause they're all great, you know,
and it's the story of redemption. It's really that, you know,
it's a good message that we're doing here. So proud to be part of it.
We're here getting at Kate's versus cons. Uh, everybody's high here.
Everybody is just placed through so much weed smoke in there.
I guarantee you every fighter flunks a drug tests have to deflect.
You're going to be fighting high off the balls.
Charles Barkley calls it the bt plate t a white people.
We've got Matt Burch from Operation Repo on a B o t version of the white
channel. True TV and we're with a business system.
Freud, Costar. Well he's a little mixed
squint rockers to sit in your seat, put from a ground. Baba Louie,
who's my Baba Lewis version. He's rough
English version of your head. Will you guys room for cops and cons?
I'm a fine line on there.
I'm kind of shading something to go more towards the cons, but you know,
the police are, I might do. Okay. Well the cons are you're,
the cons are your customers, right?
I had definitely stepped out the police order. You can't get the cons.
Some of the women that I'm only going to be politically correct. Right.
We're here with Shane crutching on the cop side. He's a military.
He's going to be fighting that I chain. Uh, what, uh,
what brought you down here? How did you, how'd you get into this? First off, uh,
back in 2006, you know, I got into it after the military and uh, here I am,
you know, I, I just answered an open audition on the Internet and here I am.
Out of 600 people, I'm on a 20 fighting.
Which con do you think is harder to fight a pothead or crack head?
Uh, I would a crack head. Yeah, definitely a crack head. You know,
I don't mind everybody's smoking pot right now in here.
I actually love it because that way, you know,
I don't have to worry about being shot walking out, you know what I mean?
Are you worried about flunking your drug tests? I already took it. I passed.
Really? I don't do after. No, no, that's great.
I would load up right now then if you knew a little extra supplement to go,
go get it in right before you walked through the red carpet
and drug dealers. No, you're good. Hey,
thanks for joining us. Good luck tonight. And you know what?
Take down my friend. Take that. Absolutely. Thank you.
So semper Fi and God blessed.
We're here at cage versus cons on the red carpet and a, I heard your name Sarah.
And what's your name?
What are you ladies here to either promote or you just here to support
you find sexier cause that's a lot of chick fetishes right there.
There's bad boys, dudes in uniforms.
How about to be a cop? A still has this uniform.
We're here with John Lick D. John, are you a one of the referees for tonight?
And I'm a time keeping them. The lowest paid guy here. The lowest paid guy here.
That's a man right there. He's rally lane.
You know what his fucking pain rate is? That's hilarious. Hey,
we're here with the cage mates. Otherwise known as the ring girls.
They'll be showing off the, uh, the big ring signs on the way a,
into new new, uh, round. So we're here with Kaleena, Danielle,
Afton and Gabriela. So a real quick girls.
Who are you for the cops or the cons?
Well, the festivities happy gone outside of the ring as a,
they've already broken up a fight here. The yellow coats are out.
This might be the only MMA match where there's a better chance of dying outside
of the octagon than there is inside
[inaudible]. So, uh, the arena is filling up as we speak.
Some of the pointers are
making their way to stay around warm up rituals.
[inaudible] here right now it's like they don't even have a call.
[inaudible] fogger miss way too. So much smell of Philly blood.
There's one walking right by us right there. So, uh,
no festivities will sue begin the worse con here at the La sports arena.
The beautiful ladies carrying the poster
[inaudible] octagon
coming up with anticipation of who will win this white top or con.
[inaudible] please.
[inaudible]
all right. Fighting fans. Here we are.
We have ringside seats for this NMA bow.
And the cage match and he's now we've got a man down already
and your face Belper. Here it is right here in your face.
All you Monday morning podcast listeners
that love a good beat down. We have it for you here. Ringside. Oh no,
he's got em in the cradle.
It looks like he's ready to pin him on his back.
We have an interlock
because now it's just force on force.
It's like wind versus water right here.
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible] charts to be stopped due to strangers.
[inaudible] you see it, Dave?
He wins by strikes. The referee stopped that fight in three months,
minutes in Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ got him a SSW.
I'm sure Jesus Christ. Inspiration.
I get him into a Afrikaans and beat the shit out of people
to kids.
Well, here comes your cop into the arena.
It's going to show a little video of him up there first.
This guy is criminal id. Every age group. This is off.
This kid came out, his baby in his mother's womb as
Brooke Crook.
William
the ring girls. Oh, there's our,
I think there's our friend Ashton that we met on the red carpet.
Hooter girls. Probably the better a that's,
I'd like to get locked in an octagon with [inaudible] does the hooter girls,
I don't think I'd want to get locked in the octagon
black suit over here with the red tennis guy. He's portraying the devil.
Apparently. She looks like Dr d. Looks like Dan Akroyd from factor Detroit.
Remember that cop verse con cops in the Blue Trunks.
Yeah. Killer cop in the blue trunks. Khan in the black trunks
places. Everyone that ref has pointed, we're ready to fight. Ooh.
Con McWilliams comes out, look at the pop.
I'm a body slam and he's got him down now submission.
It's cop on top of con right now they're starting to uh,
get in, are locked on the mat there.
That does not look fun. Fun to watch.
Not to be a part of there.
Hey, we're here with guy, Danny, Trey Ho, t a star,
the recent move and machete and many others.
We out here to see Danny cops or cause. What do you want to see? What is all
[inaudible] gets the truth, man.
I tell you what, the only thing I would,
I think the only people I'd mess around with in that ring,
the Hooters girls when they're bringing out the ring cards going down.
Absolutely. Would you ever do this?
Would you ever get yourself in a mixed up in this whole thing?
Absolutely. I don't think your agent, your agent,
probably a next bike's going to be daddy and the hooter girl.
There you go, Dan. Three or four. Thanks. Daddy
is your winter, winter for the last fight, the police
and here they come through the THC smoke
and the sent of Philly plugs.
[inaudible] the white shirt making his way. He's fired up
some tee shirts in the crowd.
It's got a lot of cheerleaders in this group. Should be an interesting fight.
Hey everybody, this is Jason Law head along with Sam Tripoli.
We're here at the cage and cons match. Um,
I believe all day. Unbelievable night, a hugest,
terrific Anza including tattoos, rap music,
and most of all octagon MMA fighting between,
you heard it, cops versus cons here at the La sports arena.
We're covering this for the Belper podcast. Hey, uh, so, uh,
to bill all your MMA, MMP Morgan pay morning podcast listeners, uh,
this is chase lauded, Sam Tripoli. Enjoy what we've got for you.
Say Bill Bird Monday morning podcast. Say Bill Burn Monday morning podcast,
Monday morning, Monday morning podcast.
Guys around, thanks a soldier
dies. But once you make this
[inaudible], it gets you [inaudible] make us comp and police puffing leaders up.
Position myself to clock [inaudible].